Elsa and Moana are two very different
characters but they've got something in
common that other Disney princesses
don't watch until the end to find out
which princess would be the last one
standing now let's find out if Moana has
what it takes to defeat the ice queen
Elsa's powers if there's one royal we
can't get enough of it's the queen of
arendelle but as many of you know Elsa
isn't your average Disney princess and
this has everything to do with her
special powers
Elsa spent most of her life thinking
that she was a freak only to realize
that she was unique it's no secret that
Elsa lacks control when it comes to her
powers which is why many of us wouldn't
dare challenge her to a duel so we all
know that Elsa has icy powers but what
else can she do what makes Elsa's powers
so special is the fact that she can
produce ice and snow at an alarming
speed in fact the young Queen can build
an entire ice castle in a few seconds
without even breaking a sweat and
believe it or not Elsa's powers continue
to grow every single year so in other
words the older she gets the more
powerful she becomes she can cause a
blizzard to manifest itself in the
middle of summer making it hard for her
enemies to see what's right in front of
them worse than that is Elsa's ability
to create a timeless state of winter so
basically the Ice Queen could prevent
the world from seeing anything but snow
if she wanted to I never knew it I was
capable but Before we jump to
conclusions let's find out what the
extent of Mona's powers are Mona's
powers at first glance Mona's powers
might pale in comparison to Elsa's but
by now we should know that Milan is not
your average girl and she tends to get
the job done Milana is built for combat
especially since she grew up on an
island and had to learn how to use her
body to her advantage
lettuce ism is beyond expressive but is
that all it takes to wipe out an ice
queen we highly doubt it luckily for
Moana her powers don't stop here on top
of being a master sailor the Islander
also has a deep connection with the
ocean
meaning it's been known to bail her out
of tough situations without mallanna's
bravery the world would have begun to
rot from the inside out and life as we
know it would come to an abrupt halt
knowing this the ocean values mo
above all and has even partied itself
and half to let her walk through it so
the question is would the ocean be able
to take on Elsa or would she turn it
into a nice ring before I got the chance
to defend it's chosen one for now it
looks like it's anybody's game but one
crucial piece of the puzzle could tip
the scales in moaña z' direction Elsa's
sidekicks where would any Disney
Princesses be without their faithful
sidekicks nowhere right most Disney
Princesses have trouble making friends
of their own which is why they tend to
turn a curious eye to pets and mystical
creatures alike I also spent most of her
life cooped up in her room out of fear
only to come face-to-face with a joyful
snowman named Olaf hi everyone I'm Olaf
and I like warm hugs
now Olaf might be as cute as a button
but he isn't exactly who you'd want on
your side when preparing for battle
Olaf's powers consist of coming undone
and putting himself back together which
isn't very useful if you ask us
however if Mona's weakness is a warm hug
then she's in a lot of trouble
luckily for Elsa she's got a village of
trolls on her side and they've proven
themselves to be pretty useful the
trolls we see in frozen our master
healers who can transform themselves
into rocks whenever they choose which
could complicate mallanna's attack plans
should she choose to sail the stormy
seas all in all Elsa's abilities are so
powerful that she hardly needs to have
allies by her side however there is
strength in numbers which is why Elsa
isn't about to turn down help anytime
soon Moana sidekicks Moana might be as
tough as nails but her two sidekicks are
as weak as they come I'm sure there's
more to hey-hey than meets the eye sure
puah and hey hey might be adorable but
they can barely defend themselves when
push comes to shove in fact mona spends
most of her time rescuing them so much
so that she chose to lead them on
montana we instead of bringing them with
her on her journey but things didn't
exactly go as planned for the princess
so basically puah and hey hey are as
useless as can be when it comes to going
to war but Mona isn't exactly helpless
without them because she's got the best
psychic of all and his name is now
you know Maui is a hero to all you doing
great although he'd probably objects to
being called her psychic he's someone
who will come to her rescue no matter
what the stakes are
Elsa might have powerful abilities but
she's no demigod Maui has the ability to
shape-shift at will which can come in
handy when fighting against an icy foe
on top of that he's got the strength of
a thousand men which can make it hard to
fight him off if he somehow manages to
get close so when it comes to beating
Elsa it's safe to say that Mona's got
the most powerful weapon of all time
Elsa's weaknesses you would think that
Elsa had a list of weaknesses but the
princess is pretty much unbeatable
however that didn't stop Hans from
kidnapping and imprisoning her Alice's
powers might be the real deal but they
also have a lot of energy to manifest so
in under an alarming amount of pressure
the queen of arendelle ended up fainting
only to be awakened in shackles knowing
that their daughter was special king
Agner and queen I dunno builds a pair of
metal restraints for their daughter
however they desperately wished that
they'd never have to use them this
mechanism cause else's hands to be
submerged in metal which prevented her
wintry magics from sleeping through but
if there's one thing that Hans should
have realized it said Elsa's power zone
only emanates from her fingertips but
from thin air as well so basically you
can capture her but you can't prevent
her from letting it snow mallanna's best
bet would be to exhaust Elsa's power
source and then imprison her by how long
could she really keep her in Chains for
all in all Elsa's number one weakness is
her love for her sister Anna so at the
end of the day Elsa's powers are useless
if her little sister is being held
hostage
Mona's weaknesses Moana isn't one to
back down when faced with a challenge
which is something to be admired however
there are times in life when running for
the hills is the only option we have
when it comes to weaknesses Moana is no
different than any of us while it's true
that she can hold her breath underwater
for long periods of time this isn't
exactly going to come in handy when
faced with an icy wielding enemy Moana
has spent her entire life on an island
and she's used to tropical weather and
blue skies so if Elsa were to turn her
world into a winter wonderland the
princess wouldn't know how to
the temperatures when it comes to
weaknesses Moana is clearly barking up
the wrong tree because she's not a
mutant like Elsa's however Moana and
Elsa do have something in common which
is putting others first
so if Elsa were to turn Mata Nui into an
ice rink Moana would have no choice but
to forfeit to save her people before we
reveal which Disney character would be
the last princess standing and let's put
some different scenarios under the scope
how Elsa would win many of us think that
Elsa has the upper hand on every single
plane but that isn't exactly true sure
she's pretty much unstoppable but there
are ways to back her into a corner Moana
might not be as powerful as her enemy
but weaker fighters tend to use their
brains instead of their abilities the
worst thing that Moana could do is
distance herself from the ocean which is
why she would lose against Elsa on the
solid ground
so if Moana were to travel to arendelle
to kick some robot she would probably
end up in the dungeons in the nick of
time
in fact it's doubtful that Moana would
even make it to arendelle considering
how cold it can get while in the
mountains Elsa's abilities can be used
in numerous ways and she can trap her
foes in an ice age without having to
snap her fingers so without the element
of surprise mallanna's efforts would be
muted by layers of snow and ice elsa
would win the fight if it occurred on
dry land but how would she fare in
Mona's world how Moana would win Moana
doesn't have any special powers but that
doesn't make her a dull enemy so while
Elsa would probably have the upper hand
in various situations Mona's got a few
tricks up her sleeve - if Elsa really
wanted to she could try to freeze every
single ocean in the world but that could
take years when taking the world's water
supply into account so if Elsa came to
Montana to fight Moana face-to-face the
ocean would come rushing in around her
without much warning
unfortunately for Elsa if she was
surrounded by the ocean she would get
submerged before she could make a
snowflake fall from the sky but that
doesn't mean that she can't put up a
fight Elsa's powers can be used from
afar so stepping foot on Mons knew he
sounds like a bad idea if she hopes to
be the last one standing
all in all freezing an entire ocean is
impossible especially since Elsa is
prone to fainting when she exhausts her
power source
the tie are we the only ones who hate
ties well we highly doubt it after all
you're here to find out which Disney
princess would conquer the other but for
argument's sake let's give both of these
Disney gems the benefit of the doubt
Moana and Elsa both have good hearts
which means that they wouldn't dare put
others in danger for their own selfish
reasons so knowing this all the other
has to do is threaten the people they
love to keep disaster at bay Moana could
send the ocean to flood arendelle
therefore wiping it off the map like
atlantis and elsa could cause winter to
become a predominant season on month nui
causing mallanna's people to perish from
lack of food and warmth so if it came to
fighting dirty
both heroines would come out on top
which would leave them to put their
differences aside and resume their
everyday lives
Elsa versus Moana so you're about to
find out which Disney princess would
shrimp the other but before defending
your favorite girl we're going to lay
out some ground rules first of all a
fair fight consists of one-on-one combat
meaning that Elsa and Moana are about to
go head-to-head without any sidekicks
involved without Maui's help or the
oceans interference all no Anna has is
her strength and intelligence which
isn't enough to keep an ice queen of a
we speak for everyone when we say that
Elsa would pulverize Moana with one
single blow to the heart
Alice has been known to freeze people's
hearts by accident so imagine if she
tried to do this on purpose
all in all Elsa's abilities are just too
powerful to beat which is why every
single Disney princess would do good by
staying on her good side I knew you
could do it although now we might stand
a chance against her she could probably
freeze him out in a few seconds tops
without the oceans backing Moana doesn't
stand a chance however she could give
Elsa a fair fight if her sidekicks were
allowed to join her ranks but even then
we're sure that Elsa would come up
kicking so there you have it guys
Elsa's the winner before you go let us
know if you think that Elsa is the most
powerful Disney Princess of all if you
think otherwise
tell us who could beat her in the
comments below and that's a wrap thanks
for tuning in to the things and see you
next time
[Music]